when your house breaks fix it and a
private toilet it's episode 28 of IMG do
you like cake do you like tacos we'll
get yourself a Taco Bell cake covered in
say cheese then say arson just don't
burn down the melting stairs wieners for
kids but zoom out to have more fun
Blitzer collects photos people have
taken with the flash visible and then
they map the flash so that the pictures
will follow your mouse as you move it
around
in fact this guy's about to contribute
no pants the only thing more fancy is
this guy
sorry I meant pineapple pants or maybe
knit pants look just knit yourself a
bender hat when you look like this you
can visit your family in jail or just
eat the chicken and use the bones to
make the kernel boogie bebop and
rocksteady and hyper realistic paintings
and for today's montage let's talk about
buzzfeed.com we could do squirrels
eating pizza dogs at Mardi Gras I mean
they're cute peppy of course they're not
always into it so let's just do pandas
join
I hope that warmed up the heart inside
you that a rat is eating what a
difference
makeup makes okay now check out this
picture of a lake can you tell what's
wrong with it look closely it might help
if you have Jedi skills but now here's
something to make you say Oh Mickey and
Minnie but look at how many is shaped
and the whipping web Chuck spider-man is
um ha ha ha well I guess perfect for
watering my chia pet bed by the way dogs
can walk dogs but I wish they'd do it
while wearing zombie high heels or at
least heels made out of actual horse
hair that give you hoods bookshelves
they can be patriotic read a ball shaped
like a curtain or contain a cozy little
nook for reading oh pretty bowl
do you like that bowl baby yeah yeah it
was made out of a human skull and this
guy loves Julia Roberts no no no I mean
he really loves Julia Roberts we now
have more than 4,000 pictures on
facebook.com slash vsauce gaming
submitted by people like you
Magnus gave us a great snack mega posts
to be okay sorry how about a pokey Pizza
submitted by Paulina and remember the
door I showed you in episode 26 that was
saying oh well Miguel realized that it
kind of resembles someone we've got a
very special episode of mind blow coming
up on Friday so stay tuned for that
subscribe to Vsauce to always know what
we're doing and as always thanks for
watching